[Music]
on this Thursday night new details about
the charity we and its close connection
to the family of the prime minister we
now says it paid hundreds of thousands
of dollars to the Prime Minister's
mother brother and wife adding fodder to
the ethics investigation chilling new
details about George Floyd's final
moments what officers said as he told
them I can't breathe and making it legal
the changes police chiefs want to
Canada's drug laws
global national with dada freezin
good evening and thanks for joining us
there's new information tonight about
how family members of prime minister
justin trudeau profited from speaking
engagements with the same charity now at
the center of an ethics investigation
the charity we was awarded a 900 million
dollar federal contract without any
competition to handle a new canada
student service grant on Friday that
contract was pulled after intense
criticism about how it was awarded and
now the charity says it has paid
Margaret Trudeau the prime minister's
mother about two hundred and fifty
thousand dollars for approximately 28
speaking engagements and it's paid
Alexandre Trudeau the Prime Minister's
brother
thirty two thousand dollars for eight
appearances we says the Prime Minister's
wife was also paid fourteen hundred
dollars for one event and has
volunteered for many others all of this
raises questions not only about the
Prime Minister's judgement that the
future of the program thousands of
students had applied for our chief
political correspondent David akin joins
me David give us more context on the
concerns here yeah well this is a big
mess for the Prime Minister it's a big
mess for the students and it's not so
great for the wee organization either
and let's talk about the wee
organisation for a minute this is a this
is a global charity that raises about 70
million dollars a year created by Mark
and Craig Kielburger its main objective
primarily get young people engaged with
citizens civic society now the Prime
Minister and his wife have frequently
appeared at wee events around the world
over the years and that has helped
burnish the image of Trudeau as a
politician for young people and when the
Trudeau government wanted to run that
900 million dollar program that
essentially would connect students with
volunteer organisations we got the
contract and we would have earned about
20 million dollars for itself as a
result and as you mentioned it was a
sole source contract and in fact when
the time came for cabinet to award the
contract the Prime Minister admitted on
Wednesday that he did not recuse himself
from any cabinet discussions about the
controversial deal
he explained that youth issues have
always been top of mind for him
throughout his political career getting
young people
involved in serving their country
recognizing their desire to build a
better Canada particularly due to
through this time of crisis is something
that I believe in deeply now whatever
his justification justin trudeau now
faces another investigation by the
Ethics Commission or Parliament's ethics
commissioner and this is the third
investigation Justin Trudeau has faced
over ethics since he became prime
minister Donna and David I believe
35,000 students have applied for
volunteer jobs under this service grant
program what's happening to them now
yeah what students are waiting for this
program to get up and running and there
is a lot of confusion there are jobs
being posted at the federal government's
website that don't exist federal
government bureaucrats are scrambling
right now to get the program up and
running they're going to deliver it
themselves and that kind of begs the
question why didn't the government just
do that in the first place why did we
have to get involved in all and that
brings us back to the judgement of
Justin Trudeau Donna lots of questions
David akin in Ottawa thank you
Global News has more insight tonight
into the security incident at the Prime
Minister's residence last week 46 year
old Corey hirin a member of the Canadian
Armed Forces faces 22 charges including
threatening death or bodily harm to the
Prime Minister
he's accused of ramming the gates of
Rideau Hall with his truck and court
documents reveal he had four loaded guns
with him some people including the
leader of the NDP called what he's
alleged to have done domestic terrorism
but that's not what he's charged with
Jeff simple joins us now with more Jeff
what have we learned about Corey her and
and a possible motive well Donna the man
accused of storming the prime minister's
residence Corey hirin wrote a letter now
we haven't seen it for ourselves but
sources say that it included a laundry
list of grievances and things that had
gone wrong in his life from his late
brother and father to the federal
firearms legislation and he blamed the
government for shutting down parliament
and parts of the economy in response to
the Cova 19 pandemic in his letter
sources say huron complained that the
lockdown would cost him his
such business and that his truck would
soon be repossessed but as a military
reservist he was still receiving a full
paycheck the letter seems to suggest
that he had financial troubles but if he
giving paid full-time as a reservist
especially in a small community that's a
good amount of money all reservists were
placed on duty during the pandemic some
deployed to long-term care homes but
hearin a ranger in Manitoba was placed
on standby and told to quarantine at
home indefinitely this was kind of a
clear case for me at least based on the
letter and the contents in the letter Oh
someone who found a lot of purpose and
meaning from his life his job his role
in the military and he started to
experience a lot of that little way
sitting at home hirin apparently spent a
lot of time online his letter and social
media posts described a conspiracy
theory that claims Bill Gates and other
elites orchestrated the covet 19
pandemic he probably had these thoughts
and ideas for a long time the impetus is
not some particular set of ideas the
ideas are there in the background for a
long time it's the emotion it's the pain
it's the depression it's not being able
to just sit there and take it anymore
sources say his letter described Canada
as a communist dictatorship he hoped his
actions would serve as a wake-up call
adding I have said more in my emails to
MPs they never responded the
Conservative Party of Canada confirms to
Global News that several of its MPs did
indeed receive emails from Huron
expressing his concerns about government
policy but according to a party
spokesperson none of those emails raised
any red flags
similarly the Canadian Armed Forces says
that it found no issues of physical or
mental health that would have prevented
his re-enrollment in the forces last
year Donna
all right Jeff's simple thank you let's
bring her in our Ottawa bureau chief
Mercedes Stevenson Mercedes this
happened at Rideau Hall
that's the governor-general's residence
and Rideau cottage is also on the grass
there that's where the Prime Minister
and his family live what larger concerns
does it raise about security there well
it's a really tough place in some ways
to have security Donna because this is
not a typical home where the head of the
country would live that is heavily
secured and designed for that purpose
Reno Hall is the traditional location
where the governor-general lives and the
grounds are open to the public in Ottawa
so lots of people apart from kovat 19
where they're closed right now would
enjoy a Sunday stroll would go skating
there in the winter it's always been
very accessible and Global News has
learned that RCMP protective detail
personnel have raised concerns about
their ability to secure the grounds at
Rideau Hall because of that public
accessibility so it's now under review
the police are trying to figure out how
they do this but there are people asking
questions about why some of these issues
were not addressed earlier for example
the gates that the man smashed through
in his truck with those loaded guns
didn't have any kind of a concrete
barrier in front of them to stop
something like that and if you look
anywhere on Parliament Hill or if
anyone's been to now suspended before
very common events like parades and
public celebrations you'd see these
concrete barriers up to prevent people
from conducting vehicle attacks so Donna
lots of questions about security they're
still that challenge of how do you keep
it open but protect the prime minister
but we do know that the RCMP has
apparently raised these concerns on more
than one occasion the Prime Minister has
faced security threats before and you
have some information about a threat
during a campaign event last fall so I'm
sure Donna you and all of our viewers
will remember the prime minister coming
out in a bulky bulletproof Kevlar vest
at the time he was in the vast the Prime
Minister's office the Liberal Party and
the RCMP wouldn't tell us what the
threat was we know that that threat now
was in fact that there was a person
allegedly in the audience with a gun a
bus driver who was working to drive
people to this campaign rally approached
the RCMP saying she had seen a man
holding a black pistol on his hands and
her description was so convincing to the
RCMP that they believed there was a
credible threat they
also made the recommendation at that
point to the Trudeau campaign that they
should cancel the event or not go out in
the crowd instead they waited 90 minutes
while the RCMP cold in the crowd they
never found the gun or the man and they
made the decision to go ahead with the
event Donna
all right Mercedes Stevenson in Ottawa
thank you now to the pandemic the World
Health Organization has acknowledged
that it's possible the novel coronavirus
may be transmitted through aerosols
which can linger in the air and spread
further than two meters until now the
organization is focused on transmission
by large droplets expelled when a person
coughs or sneezes in a new scientific
brief the w-h-o says microscopic
droplets that can float further could
also transmit the virus more than 200
scientists had urged the w-h-o to update
its guidance after mounting evidence of
airborne transmission the organization
at first resisted it now says this may
help explain outbreaks in enclosed
settings like churches bars and
restaurants and it's advising people to
avoid crowded indoor spaces that are
poorly ventilated it also says more work
needs to be done to fully understand
transmission the w-h-o also says the
pandemic is getting worse and it says
world leaders must work harder together
to get the situation under control
tonight more than 550,000 people are
known to have died from Co vid 19 around
the world in more than 12.1 million
people have tested positive one of the
world's most worrying hotspots is still
the United States it shattered yet
another daily case record yesterday more
than 62 thousand Americans tested
positive at least five states Missouri
Texas Tennessee Utah and West Virginia
set single day records and hospital ICUs
in several cities have now reached
capacity president Donald Trump has ever
since he got elected refused to release
his tax returns today the US Supreme
Court ruled he does not have the
absolute right to block their release
the ruling opens the door to new york
prosecutors and potentially Congress
getting to see his financial records our
Washington bureau chief Jackson Prosecco
is with me Jackson what will this ruling
trigger
well Donna the headline here is that
President Donald Trump's claims of
absolute power do not exist and he is
not exempt from legal scrutiny the court
here looked at two different cases in
one the prosecutors in New York wanted
Trump's financial records as they
investigate hush money payments made to
two women who claim they had affairs
with him and in a 7 to 2 decision the
court sided with those prosecutors
saying that Trump is not above the law
when it comes to being compelled to
produce evidence for a grand jury the
second case involved a subpoena from
Democrats in Congress who want access to
Trump's business and banking records
they're trying to investigate any
foreign entanglements or other alleged
financial crimes in another seven to two
decision that issue was punted back to
the lower courts to debate issues around
separation of powers but basically it
leaves the door open for Congress to get
those documents some day now Donna as
you can imagine Trump is not happy he
has been firing off angry tweets all day
and reacted a short time ago
well the rulings were basically starting
all over again sending everything back
down to the lower courts and you start
all over again and so from a certain
point satisfied from another point I'm
not satisfied because frankly this is a
political witch-hunt the likes of which
nobody has ever seen before it's a pure
witch-hunt it's a hoax Jackson president
Trump is the first u.s. president since
Jimmy Carter not to release his tax
returns does this really mean he will
and if so how soon well here's where
both of today's decisions sort of work
out as a win for Trump the president can
still challenge the scope and relevance
of the subpoena from prosecutors in New
York and he has sort of long argued that
they're on a wild fishing expedition
here trying to dig up dirt and the lower
courts will still have to hear the case
of those congressional subpoenas what
this means is that it's unlikely that
either matter will be resolved before
November's election so even if Trump is
ultimately forced to produce those
documents that he has so carefully
guarded he'll either be in his second
term or out of office by the time it
happens Donna all right Jackson Prosecco
in Washington Thanks
new court documents have been released
that give us a detailed account of
George Floyd's final moments
the unarmed black man who died after a
police officer kneeled on his neck
transcripts of police body camera
footage shed light on key parts and what
was said and what exactly happened
Eric Sorenson has the chilling details
and a warning some of what's in this
story could be disturbing for some
viewers the killing of George Floyd
sparked protests for racial justice
around the world
the eyewitness video of his arrest was
chilling new transcripts suggest Floyd
at first was afraid he'd be shot by
police mr. officer please don't shoot me
man please
police struggled to get Floyd into a
vehicle the transcript taken from police
body cameras is unsparing Floyd says I
can't breathe officer Lane get him on
the ground
Floyd let go of me man I can't breathe
by the time he was down Floyd was
desperate but immobilized bystander
video captured his anguished plea the
transcript shows he uttered I can't
breathe no fewer than 20 times at one
point Floyd says my neck hurts
everything hurts I need some water or
something please please I can't breathe
officer officer Chauvin then stop
talking stop yelling Floyd you're going
to kill me man Chauvin then stop talking
stop yelling it takes a heck of a lot of
oxygen to talk all four officers
involved were fired by Minneapolis
police derrick Chauvin was the officer
with his knee on Floyd's neck
he's charged with second-degree murder
the other three are charged with aiding
and abetting murder the lawyer for one
of them former officer Thomas Lane wants
those charges dropped
because Chauvin was the senior officer
making decisions Lane's argument says
this legal analyst Derrick children had
not shown up and had not been the senior
officer George Floyd would still be
alive
during his angin izing final minutes
Floyd said tell my kids I love them he
called out to his momma several times
his final words please please please
even before the detailed transcripts
Floyd's family was convinced he was
killed because of race
my nephew getting murdered by a damn
madman in the middle of the street for
what reason because of the color of his
skin
when George Floyd had stopped moving a
bystander said
police he's not even breathing right now
bro you think that's cool
officer Chauvin asked you guys alright
though officer lane yeah I mean my knee
might be a little scratched but I'll
survive
Eric Sorensen Global News Toronto a
surprising request from Canada's police
chiefs coming up why they say simple
possession of illicit drugs should be
legal
a group representing police chiefs
across Canada is calling for
decriminalizing the possession of small
amounts of illicit drugs the Canadian
Association of Chiefs of Police says
substance use and addiction are a public
health issue and it's recommending a
national task force be created to look
into drug policy reform the president of
the organization Vancouver police chief
Adam Palmer says arresting people for
simple possession has proven ineffective
and doesn't save lives being addicted to
a controlled substance is not a crime
and should not be treated as such
we recommend that Canada's enforcement
based approach for possession be
replaced with a health care approach
that diverts people from the criminal
justice system Palmer says the health
care model could include increased
access to treatment and social services
Canada has a fentanyl overdose crisis
and a toxic drug supply that has killed
more than 15,000 people still ahead a
nuclear deal in the trial of British
Columbia's deadliest gang shooting
there's an update tonight on the case of
one of BC's most notorious gangsters
Jamie bacon and his brothers are well
known to the police and tonight vacant
has pleaded guilty to one count of
conspiracy in the deaths known in BC as
the Surrey six it was a gang turf war
that resulted in two innocent people
being killed as Robin Gill reports the
mother of one of those victims says she
hopes justice is finally served Ilene
Mohan is always on time for court she
hardly ever misses a legal proceeding
because it involves the murder of her
only child I'm not here to look for
revenge Robin you know I'm here just to
seek justice for my son because this
crime came to my doorstep we did not go
to this crime we were a crime free
family in 2007 twenty-two old
Christopher Mohan was returning to his
apartment in a Vancouver suburb
unbeknownst to him an alleged drug
dealer who lived in the building and his
associates for the target of a turf war
Mohan and another innocent bystander at
schellenberg a repairman were caught in
the crossfire
it was infamously dubbed the Surrey six
the deadliest gang shooting in BC's
history jamie bacon a member of the red
scorpions gang has pleaded guilty to one
count of conspiracy to commit murder and
counseling to commit murder in a
different case it's a so-called
two-for-one deal that takes the charge
of first-degree murder
off the table mr. bacon is
content to have the proceeding complete
very soon and put all this behind the
crown and defense both agreed to a plea
deal now the question is the actual
sentence for bacon who's already served
six years in custody he has nowhere to
run
like a coward again he took the he
pleaded guilty but with the bargain plea
after thirteen years of agony and
reliving her son's final moments every
time she's in court she hopes there's
finally some justice for her family
Robin Gill Global News Vancouver next
the rare gorilla is caught on camera in
Nigeria
new photos of the world's rarest great
apes have been released and they reveal
some good news these images taken in
southern Nigeria shows seven cross river
gorillas and with them are a number of
babies only 300 of this rare subspecies
of the gorilla are known to exist along
the nigeria cameroon border once thought
to be extinct after decades of poaching
they were rediscovered in 1980
conservationists say the sighting is a
sign the gorillas are reproducing and
recovering that is global national for
this Thursday I'm Donna Friesen today is
known about day and in order of that we
leave you tonight with some beautiful
views from pangur tongue on Baffin
Island thanks for watching
hope to see you here again tomorrow take
care of yourselves bye bye
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]